[Musique]
sur cinquante ans on a décidé de
proposer un village de trois semaines du
19 juillet au 6 août avec avec un vrai
équilibre entre les activités sportives
et d'activités culturelles et certaines
activités libres donc tout se déroule
dans l'espace événementiel qui est
l'ancienne piscine à vagues c'est un
espace de 4 hectares entièrement plein
air est entièrement clôturé et sécurisé
pas trop branches et j'avais parlé de
loisirs à la voile le canoë en fonction
de la météo à l'équitation est aussi une
petite activité qu'on a un minigolf
présentation par la terrible annonce à
ses activités gérées en parler de
loisirs et ensuite on vient rajouter
toute une panoplie d'activités
on n'a pas du tout la petite de mettre
en place et là on aura du rugby à 5 du
beach handball du basket ball en 3
contre 3 donc ça ça va être la nouveauté
de cette année puisque c'est une
discipline olympique et sur les
activités plus culturelles
on aura des initiations aux gestes qui
sauvent
on aura une exposition sur les jeux
olympiques concrètement un a déjà prévu
la distribution de petits goodies qu'on
va essayer utile et qu'ils soient pas
simplement simplement des petits objets
ajouté effectivement quelques quelques
mini événement on pense déjà à des
cancers on pense à une séance de cinéma
de plein air avec le film sur jesse
owens pourquoi pas voilà on va vraiment
marquer ses dix ans avec quelques mini
événement en début et en fin de village